stephen colbert i just love him and he
shared his pre-show ritual he does
something interesting before every show
he told the wall street journal that
every night before he goes out he slaps
himself in the face
not once but twice yes he said hard
enough to wish he hadn't done it and
it's his way of bringing himself present
like into the moment he says i'll never
get another chance to do those jokes or
interview that person or be present for
that audience so he wants to wake
himself up just so he can be there i
love stephen colbert so much that it
like hurts my soul
um this is interesting uh the slapping
is a unique approach especially twice
yeah um but i really take some life
lessons from the you will never
do this interview again you will never
be with this group of guests which is
called an audience but i think of it as
guests and i i think that
all slapping aside um
i i love the we won't get this moment
back so going into it knowing that might
shift the perspective i like it i like
it too yeah different way of thinking
well next there is scientific proof that
nostalgia makes us feel better martha
stewart reports that the chinese academy
of sciences has found that looking at
nostalgic images reduces pain isn't this
fascinating they hooked subjects up to
an
fmri machine and put a heat generator on
their arm and then they showed them
modern or nostalgic images the group
looking at nostalgic cartoons or games
from childhood felt less pain from the
bernie thing
and the um and had reduced activities in
parts of the brain associated with pain
perception so i mean gosh if you got
some cramps break out the bug's bunny
ross what do you think about that i
don't i mean okay good i think good but
not for me no if i have a headache i'm
not going to turn on gem in the
holograms give me an advil you know what
i mean i
i mean sex in the city cuts painful oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah i'll
do that
i didn't know we could do that yes okay
big creamy bowl of macaroni and cheese
deluxe and some sex in the city is
totally my go-to for painting yeah take
me to the aid in years and that will
cure anything right
okay well listen if you love love like
we love love we've got a modern love
story that shows you can find love just
about anywhere if you look this story is
going viral right now
jonah taylor recently received a scratch
record from an online store he bought a
record well when he logs in to call
customer service he seemed to really hit
it off with the customer service rep
named pablo and after his issue was
resolved very smoothly by pablo by the
way jonah took a real leap drew you're
gonna love this
uh he asked are you single
and it turns out pablo was single
and the rest is history they've already
gone on their first zoom date and they
say they are taking things slow but they
found love
over the customer service line
you guys
i love this i'll press one to speak to
an agent press o to oh
oh
i love it drew well i say we go out
there and we be bold and respectful
but
you know ask why not
[Music]